well I mean what is what is the natural
community done to to stop Mimas campaign
of ethnic cleansing against you know 1.2
million Rohingya Muslims as I said
nothing
what is eagerness community doing
against China's over 20 plans up to 12
million Wigan Muslims at the moment
nothing I mean not only is the world you
know an ego Rwanda genocide which
certainly didn't have Muslims at both
but if you look at the track record of
the international community stepping in
to halt genocide where the majority of
the population is Muslim it hasn't been
coming we can also look at Syria what
does the international community do to
hold you know Assad is killing of
displacing about 12 million mostly Sunni
Muslims in Syria speaking about you
mentioned China talked to us about some
of the things like the GPS you write
about the Jeep the the you bring in a
we're creating awareness about many
things that are going on there but for
people who are ignorant to what is going
on there's many events unfolding can you
bring us up to speed on that yeah I mean
in the far western region of what is
mainland China is focused on was
actually its own nation state up until
1949 and China invaded and occupied the
region as occupied you know that part of
the China well what really isn't China
is occupied is Turkish and ever since
now for a long period the Chinese
government left we go Muslims in that
region pretty much to see their own but
things sort of changed in the 1980s and
trying to begin a crackdown to snap out
any effort by wiggins to you know
recreate or to throw off the Chinese
occupation I think you had a war on
terror which the US war on terror which
started in 2001 and okay of China a
veneer or a fig leaf to carry out what
it called its own war on terror against
Wigan Muslims
in this focus on conflating you know
Wigan Muslim separatists ambitions or
aspirations we have Islamic terrorism
so that crackdown has been ever since
has been really enforced you know it's
particularly in the last in the last
decade summer to show that we're giving
Muslims now I cannot exit China
anybody who directed China is arrested
I've interviewed a number of her wicked
Muslim refugees one in Australia where
his wife and child they've tried to join
me in my food here at handy's refugee
status in a trailer when they arrived at
the airport she was detained the nine
month old baby was also arrested with
her there once the baby turns one under
Chinese law they will put her into the
prison for five years and they're gonna
sell the baby on the on the black market
now that's just one case of what's
happening there and you know the world
is completely fun now for other weekend
Muslims their cell phone to track this
their their cars are located with GPS
tracking devices if they want to move
out of East Turkestan and maybe go to
Beijing or Shanghai and then I have the
seat of special permits to do so they're
forced him to re-education camps to you
know to force them to dance Islam those
who do not dance announced Islam and
then put into every hard labor camps or
in prison for a you know up to five to
ten years even weaker Muslim families
are forced to have a Chinese Communist
representative in their home for Chinese
nationals holidays it's part of
indoctrinating into you know the the
Chinese state ideology
now our women also being I mean it's
this is what will you see a new a
modern-day Inquisition sounds like yeah
it really is a you know what I you know
I read their story recently and he's a
white was them living in the United
States
his wife was detained arrested forced
conversion and in prison she was
tortured and working
so and he's actually trying to sue the
Chinese government he's told me he's
already had to assassinate assassination
attempts on his life one time when he
returned a trainer in it just suited
Chinese government for the deputies like
and I don't harm the US which has
reported to the FBI when I asked the
people how to try to carry out these
assassination attempts and he said that
the Chinese government very good
particularly the particular intelligence
agencies and making a traffic accident
or making an assassination look like a
traffic accident he believes it two
attempts on his life or we're done in
that manner I heard women are being
forced not only you said forced
conversions but what to leave Islam are
I heard that they're also being forced
to marry certain to have forced
marriages to what is the Communist Party
members yeah and there have been stories
of forced marriages to these not exactly
sure I can't give you the numbers but I
have anecdotal accounts of that
happening but I mean family has been
separated all the time I mean even now
that police Chinese police in that
province have these new smart glasses so
there were these glasses which area pico
special regime there you know identify a
facial recognition that things back into
a database and then write again fired
what a wig in a Muslim on a train on a
box on her plane even walking in the
street and if that weekend was on is
wanted for any reason could be a parking
violation and just isn't an excuse to
make the arrest
forced into a reiteration camp and in
their process the court anyway wow this
is just so amazing to hear it's sowing
incredible you can't wrap your mind you
know people are sitting at home here and
enjoying many of the things that we have
we're not thinking about outside of the
box what's going on in the rest of the
world but this isn't in in our day and
age this is actually happening what what
can people do what could people who are
who haven't heart I have a
art they they want to make a change what
could someone do to to speak out against
his whoa what do you suggest
yeah I mean it's very frustrating
because I mean even what's interesting
is not one single Muslim leader of a
muslim-majority nation state has offered
one word of condemnation or what Shriner
is doing it's a weakened Muslim
population and that's for you know a
very simple reason is trans economic
power is so vast and so strong that so
many nations Satan become you know
independent or dependent on the Chinese
economy and they fear that by speaking
out and denouncing what China is doing
in its doukasen well you know result in
you know economic punishment a lot of
trade a lot of foreign or Battaglia's
investment in their safes so the
international community at the nation
state level is completely frozen on the
weekend was long issue and it's really
only left to activist young people who
are making noise about this they're
actually Wiggin Muslim refugees who have
been fortunate enough to escape
China tell us are trying to get back to
your question what can we do is yeah it
just make as much noise as possible so
you know I you know so I just speak to
Muslims on a daily basis were completely
unfamiliar which is which is what we've
what is happening in in each focus and
so I encourage people to make noise on
social media other the more noise and
you know that gets the ball rolling in
you know and hopefully creating a
climate where political action can
follow yeah